c'est dans ce contexte que pour la
première fois à Blois avait lieu la
Marche des fiertés ce samedi malgré les
tensions récentes la manifestation a
rassemblé 700 personnes dans une
ambiance joyeuse et colorée mais qui a
mis en lumière le manque de structure
d'accueil à destination des personnes
LGBTI dans le Loir-et-Cher Aurélie
Renaud était sur place
le top départ est donné au port de la
Creusille une première marche pour Blois
organisée par le planning familial de
Loir-et-Cher et pour nous il était très
important aujourd'hui de se lancer à
cette première Marche des fiertés et que
le planning puisse porter ça bah c'est
chouette parce que du coup c'est des
thématiques enfin qu'on aborde depuis
plusieurs années et mais qu'on entend
quand même de plus en plus parler
notamment le public qui peut venir à
notre local dans nos interventions et
donc voilà c'était le bon timing pour
nous en tout cas pour l'organiser cette
année les 700 participants sont venus
entre amis en famille en couple tous
mains dans la main pour défendre les
droits LGBT je pense qu'il faut vivre
avec son temps pour vivre on est en 2023
et donc on a autant de droits que
tous quoi donc on est humain donc là on
se rend compte on peut discuter de nos
parcours aussi que ça soit pour de
l'adolescence voir en France ou même du
futur ou justement la PM tout ça donc
c'est super important par rapport à ça
une marche des fierté très symbolique
car elle a lieu au lendemain de la mise
en examen d'un lycéen de 17 ans suspecté
d'avoir lancé un explosif qu'il avait
fabriqué dans les locaux du Centre LGBT
de tours
gbti de tou Touraine ça commence à être
vraiment très dur pour les associations
donc même chez aide nous on a on essaie
de défendre et on fait attention aussi
avec nos militants en région Centre il
existe donc des centrales GBT à Tours
Bourges et Orléans mais pas encore à
Blois